il faut qu'on revienne sur le mode de de
fixation du prix des médicaments
face aux industriels je pense que
aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une échelle de
perroquet
qui n'a plus de sens c'est quoi des
chefs de perroquet c'est à chaque fois
que vous avez un médicament innovant je
vais répondre à votre question je l'ai
pas oublié mais il faut que vous
compreniez quel est mon arrière-pensée
vous avez à chaque fois que vous avez un
médicament innovant s'il apporte le
moindre bénéfice thérapeutique par
rapport à un médicament existant
l'industriel a le droit d'avoir un prix
supérieur aux médicaments de référence
existant
cette politique de fixation du prix elle
date des années 70 où voulait promouvoir
l'innovation et faire en sorte que les
industriels
investissent dans l'innovation et
produisent des médicaments plus
performants
40 ans après
l'innovation a été très importante
notamment en cancérologie et donc vous
avez une accélération de l'innovation et
avec cette échelle de perroquet
aujourd'hui vous payez des médicaments
qui apportent trois mois de vie en plus
l'équivalent de 100.000 dollars alors
que 3 mois de vie gagné en plus il y a
10 ans c'était 8000 euros donc en fait
cette échelle de perroquet fait à chaque
fois vous montez le prix quel que soit
le bénéfice et donc quand vous mettez
côte à côte l'innovation des années 2000
avec l'innovation des années 2020 et
bien pour trois mois de vie j'ai gagné
en plus vous avez quintuplé voire
multiplier par 10 le prix que vous êtes
capable de enfin le
prix que vous accordez à ce bénéfice
thérapeutique de par cette fixation de
du prix et cette échelle de perroquet
qui est dans la loi en fait donc et elle
apporte en fait des inégalités
invraisemblables parce que comme
innovation est très importante en
cancérologie vous accordez au prix la
vie en cancérologie des sommes de la
sécurité sociale faramineuses et vous
payez pas du tout autant d'argent pour
des patients diabétiques aujourd'hui ne
serait-ce que parce que l'innovation n'a
pas été suffisante pour que cette
échelle de prix augmente aussi vite
qu'en cancero et donc vous regardez un
an de vie gagné en cancero ou un nom de
vie gagner dans une autre pathologie ça
n'a rien à voir en terme de d'effort
fournis par la collectivité ça pose
problème moi je l'ai souvent dit aux
associations de patients vous devriez
vous préoccuper quand même de l'équité
de ce qu'on dépense et donc pour moi
tout ça nécessite impérativement que
l'on revoit la politique du prix de la
fixation du prix vis-à-vis des indus